Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn is time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
And Ah,
just checking in on you.
How are you?
Um,
I am in Warsaw,
Poland and I actually have a special guest.
My only friend here.
The only person I really know in Poland.
Mr. Paul Versey.
Yeah.
Paul,
how are you?
Thanks for having me here.
Um,
excellent.
Maybe I'll do it like this.
I'll just sit there and I'll try and move this cause I don't have the equipment
that I need.
Um,
Paul.
Yeah.
Um,
since we last spoke.
Yeah.
Well it's been a long time since you've been on the podcast,
but this week we've been to Germany,
Astonia,
Latvia,
Hungary in Poland.
Yeah.
And uh,
it's been a great time.
Okay.
Hands Down Budapest,
hands down,
food pass,
hands down.
Buda,
Budapest.
Last night Budapest was,
Budapest was,
they will all great.
But Budapest was so good last night I was on stage.
Okay.
And I,
and I had that thought in my head like,
dude,
I think I tape a special here.
That was,
that felt like a hot American crowd.
Yeah.
It didn't matter where you like,
it didn't matter.
We were in Hungary,
they were ready.
It was great.
Lottery trio was the best hackles.
Lot fee.
I enjoyed Lafayette,
the one,
uh,
you know,
there was a couple of times in life for you.
You felt alone up there.
But due to Astonia well,
10 minutes before I go on stage and granted I'm going,
obviously I'm going cold.
The only thing I got is Kenny going,
we have a space.
You're really gonna love them right column.
So to Kenny,
shout out to him,
he brings me up and uh,
10 minutes before I go up,
the guy goes,
yeah,
standups only been here for eight years.
It got introduced in 2010.
And I was like,
that's a little unnerving to hear before you go out there.
But like,
yeah,
they were dressed up really nice to theater was beautiful.
Yeah.
And a,
you go into something and it was just,
it's like you said,
man,
those Baltic states,
it was fucking in a little bit,
this is a little bit something like deputy,
they're very,
very fucking smart and logical.
Astonia was like the best look and crowd,
they would like dress so nicely.
I felt like a,
I felt like out of place.
It's theater was too nice for what we were saying.
Yeah.
Um,
but Munich,
it was also like Budapest by little
Munich and in Budapest where uh,
we're for fucking and Munich goes with three 30 show when they were a hot crowd.
But all of them have been a great,
but like those were the two cities that you didn't have to even think that you
were over somewhere.
But like,
so anyways,
I'd been on the road with birthday now for like a week and I'm a moody son of a
bitch,
so I know I'm driving them nuts.
But uh,
you know it's funny is dude,
you're way of talking like I was just joking.
Like what did you just say?
Like volume it up.
Volume up.
Yeah.
You said volume it up.
Like I was trying to,
trying to figure out,
cause the recording seemed like you just have your own way of speaking and I
have to try to figure out what the fuck you talking about.
I'm like,
this,
this is coming to,
it's too quiet in a corner.
You're just going like,
well,
you know,
just,
just volume it up.
Well,
like the volume it,
you,
me turn up the volume.
Uh Oh no,
no,
you're just a,
Oh,
they did it.
Their bread before he came in.
You did they,
I mean,
just the,
what'd you say?
Wipe it down with Windex.
Windex that down.
Imagine if they want.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
the thing is to me and my,
my mother,
I got this from my mother.
My mother always says,
um,
like turn the lights.
Uh,
like we don't say turn the lights on and off.
We say a cut the lights.
No,
not cut the lights.
What is it?
Uh,
oh fuck.
I forgot.
I have another thing in my wife goes,
I'd never heard that.
Turned the lights up and I'll turn the lights off.
You don't even know this language.
It's so crazy.
You don't even know what you saying.
Yeah.
I don't say turn the lights the way that other people do do funny shit today.
So we're,
we're leaving in Budapest.
Oh,
this is great.
And we've been taking these small propeller planes and shit,
cause you know they're short little flights here and uh,
so it's one of those deals,
you go to the gate and then you get on a bus and then he'd take the bus out to
the propeller plane and then,
you know what I like about them?
They don't give a fuck if your bag doesn't fit.
They're like,
I just shove it under the seats.
They get on the seat next to you that it's not like this fucking post nine 11.
You know,
why are you being hostile?
Get your bag off the fucking plane the way they are in the states.
So I get on the thing,
the bus and for,
as he got on the bus first and I said,
hey.
And he had a weird looking face.
What's up?
He said,
dude,
you just missed it.
This guy just asked me to sit next to him.
Like some total like gay shit.
Like he like pat the seat next to him.
I saw Paul and he the pad on the seat or whatever.
Right.
So like I'm like,
really?
I go,
well maybe it's like a European thing or whatever.
But I did think it was weird cause the bus was so big and there were the faulty
seat.
It was all these seats.
Yeah.
So then later,
first he's looking at the guy and he's laughing at him,
going through,
look at his little hat.
His hat doesn't fit his head and I'm just looking over it.
And I knew it wasn't Jewish.
I knew it was something religious.
It turned out was like a Muslim.
It was definitely bigger than a Yamaka.
Yeah,
it's bigger than younger.
So it was like,
it was the Muslim that right.
And then we finally realized,
I'm looking at the guy and he looks just like [inaudible] and I'm going,
wait a minute,
this guy's probably Muslim.
Thought you were Muslim.
He's in fucking Budapest and he wanted to hang with you.
And then he ends up and then with funny he's,
he's,
he was freaking you out.
And then in your seat was like 10 [inaudible] and Kenny goes,
watch,
he'll probably have 10 a and then the fucking guy gets on,
he's got 10,
eight and then he goes out to you,
cause you're fine.
Are you Arabic?
But the ones,
so bill was right,
but the one thing you left out in the story is when I did get on alone,
when he said,
uh,
I,
you know,
like I'm a free people that don't know me.
I'm kind of like even you said,
I get a little too nice with my small talk like,
oh,
so it snowed here hot like the audience shit dude.
You talked to that kid with the sneakers that went on forever.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
I can just talk to a stranger.
My grandfather was like that,
right?
So I look at this guy,
I smile and he smiles back overly like too much.
And then he goes,
he said something,
I didn't say it.
And then he patted the seat next to him and looked at me like,
hey,
I have this seat.
Wait and for you.
And that made me like a
little weird because it was all empty.
So I'm going,
Oh shit,
maybe this guy.
So,
but bill says,
dude,
he goes,
he may think you're a Muslim.
So sure enough,
like he said,
the guy comes next to me,
couldn't have been sweeter.
I go,
sorry about the bed.
No problem,
no problem.
And then he leans over and I'm just going,
fuck,
Oh God,
fuck your bill is right.
Let's not let them,
it's bad that you are right.
But he goes,
are you a Arabic?
And I go,
I go,
cause I didn't,
he goes out to pick you Arabic.
And he like pointed to my face and I go,
no.
And he goes,
you look at her beck and I go,
motherfucker.
Bill was right.
Literally wanted me to sit with him.
He thought I was Muslim.
How fuck okay.
You thought he was a gay guy with a little hat.
That's the funniest shit ever.
Oh my God dude.
All right,
I want to talk to you cause this is something that is gradually going into your
act,
which I think is gonna make you stand out and it's going to be your voice in it
is your,
uh,
your ideas of luxury,
your ideas of leisure,
amenities,
amenities you're have,
you're big into it.
Many of these,
like if there's a mint on your pillow,
when you come back,
you feel like,
yes,
that means something.
It does.
And this is why I love working with you.
Not only that,
we're friends,
you got class never in a back to school.
You know,
you've got 91.
Mr Mallon,
you've got class.
He goes,
I rubbed off from you buzzy.
The guy that redid his college dorm,
never.
Hey,
you made the college dorm.
He knocked out walls.
No,
but you go,
you like your five star.
You know,
you're,
I wouldn't say you're not a cunt about it,
but you like,
you like Nice Shit.
You know,
I love,
listen,
I stayed in a bunch of Super Eights and Oh yeah.
And Motel six is yeah,
but I don't,
I don't stay at the,
the fucking Ritz Carlton Penthouse when I like working with you too because you
just like,
you know,
certain things and I liked that.
But uh,
yes to so I love the little things.
I love to slippers.
I loved it.
I loved the chocolate.
I love the,
I love the joy that you get out of it.
And it's just so fucking funny.
I,
I don't know why,
why those little things mean something cause so slippers to,
if,
if you've got those slippers for Christmas,
you'd be like,
it's my wife cheating on me.
Yeah.
These things are so fucking cheap there.
They never fit your feet.
But you know,
you come in like,
dude,
you just see the robe.
Yeah,
I know.
Oh my God.
I don't know why bill,
they had chocolates.
Yeah,
you would think that I was raised.
You would think that I was raised on the streets.
I don't know what,
I don't know what it is.
You sitting there.
We were on the airplane going like,
Dude,
you know what,
we should start an airline first of all,
like those costs,
billions of dollars.
And he goes,
we'd call it luxury air.
And I immediately go,
I wouldn't fly that.
You're like,
well,
you wouldn't fly it against that.
It's just too on the nose.
It's trying too hard.
I feel like I'd go in there and they'd be like,
you know,
like a,
like a faucet that was like gold,
but it wasn't real gold,
but it was golden color.
Like look at the luxury invitation Rolodex.
Yeah.
All of that.
Um,
so we were trying to come up,
but you would fly an airline that had 25 all first class seats,
leather,
all beds.
This is,
this is what we were talking about right when I was like that there's a
difference between,
uh,
like classy,
right?
Gardy.
There's refined and then there's showing up and there's just certain people,
I don't know if either one is right.
I won't be like that.
If I look at like a Ferrari,
a guy my age can drive a Ferrari and not look like an asshole.
Do you keep yourself in shape and you can tell like this guy's,
he's into,
he's into like,
he knows how to work on cars.
He worked his way up.
I'm not talking about some fucking jerk off,
you know,
pinky ring type of thing.
But like a Lamborghini,
a Lamborghini is a young man's car.
That's for like,
you're in your 20s,
you're shirtless.
You got like a Cheetah on like a fucking leash.
Like,
like I,
I feel like the Lamborghini is obnoxious where the,
the Ferrari is the shit,
right?
Like they,
like if they were people like the Lamborghini would be walking around and
talking about how much money it had,
where the fucking,
the Ferrari guy would be like,
chill.
See,
here's the thing,
my Greek side is the class here,
but my Sicilian kind of goes in and is like,
and,
and we have that battle,
but most of those cars are Italian that,
that's made by Italian stuff.
So I know,
but that's why I see,
I like the chain.
I love the gold chain.
It's like,
pardon me,
I love it,
but can you got to your chain?
You literally said that the gold chain completed yet.
Yes.
You and Neon is love.
That yon is almost cried when I said that.
Yeah,
the gold changes did something,
but I can't go pinky ring.
That's where I draw the line.
So I think that that's the Greek where it's like,
no,
you can't wear my father hundred percent full blooded Italian,
the whole thing.
He just goes,
he's,
he's like into the Jews.
He goes,
he goes,
would you go
second chain?
I would go second chain if it complimented this the right way.
So that,
that,
that's the high water mark that change.
Yeah.
I mean I would go one more,
no,
no bumps it.
But the other one would,
would,
would compliment it.
You wouldn't,
you wouldn't then?
No.
Maybe even like a little thinner than this around it or what?
It would compliment it.
That's it.
Oh,
okay.
Just an accent.
An accent.
You look good in a chain.
No,
I wouldn't get a Jane.
I think I had a thin rope.
It would look good on you.
A thin one.
Yeah,
but then I would start looking like something that I'm not,
which I'm not something you ever wear a chain with a cross ever.
I grew up in the 80s.
Of course I did.
I had the,
uh,
but I wanted the smooth one around and my mother got me the one that's like
that,
which wasn't in style.
Then the other one was the total Guido fucking,
the flat,
the rope I had,
I able to be like,
what do you at?
Oh,
you got this.
Okay.
So,
um,
yeah,
no,
I think this,
this,
this certain thing about if you have a chain,
there's a certain level of shit you're going to talk.
There's a certain level of,
of,
you know,
there's something that,
the,
you can go out and get.
I would wear with something like that if I was playing a character in movie,
but like,
I know I'm not a chain guy.
No.
Are you a leather jacket guy?
You'll wear the nice leather?
Uh,
yeah.
I like what the jacket was like a,
but I wouldn't get a motorcycle.
One.
I get one that was like really like top leather leather,
but it was like a,
it was,
I'm wearing it because it's the last,
it's cold outside.
Yeah,
you're not alive.
Yeah.
I'm not trying to wear it to be like,
oh,
look at my leather coat.
I can't pull it off,
dude.
I'm a fucking pasty northern European guy.
You know?
I didn't grow up in southeastern south.
He was Southie.
I wasn't like one of these,
you know?
I mean,
I basically,
I didn't care about fighting somebody else until I got to junior high and
everybody else grew and I didn't grow and then kids really could fucking fight.
Once I started seeing people getting their teeth knocked out and nose is broken,
I was just like,
all right.
You know,
I mean,
I don't,
I don't want to go into this world.
I'm too fucking slow.
You know?
I have the anger to do this,
but I'm going to lose.
And you know,
read Ed's dude,
you barely touch us.
We looked like we fucking fell off a motorcycle.
We just bruise so easily.
Were you ever a,
are you,
you're not a sneaker guy,
you're not a,
you're not,
were you ever like,
uh,
I like sneakers when I was,
when I was a kid and I do like some old school ones,
but I got to admit that subset of American culture where you know you're in your
forties,
you're in your 50s and your still dressing like it's the first day of school at
the bus stop.
We have like the brand like Aye.
Aye.
You've made me like respect Jordans.
I like them in that type of shit.
But it is hilarious to me that we've worked some of the greatest theaters in
America and you walk out with a pair of sneakers on and like,
you know,
you chain out and shit like that.
And to you that's like dressing up.
But where I'm from like um,
oh,
uh,
what's his face?
Nate Cordrey.
I worked with him on a,
on a fucking,
uh,
the heat and we were joking about Boston,
we were shooting there and he said,
he goes,
dude,
it's like totally acceptable in Massachusetts to show up to a holiday party
wearing like a Tom Brady Jersey.
Like people be like,
Oh,
you've got the away one.
that's cool.
I like that.
It's got the Superbowl patch on it.
So I came from more like a sports culture like that,
but um,
there is something,
uh,
I think also,
I think it's because of being in this business,
which has so much shit about your age,
you know,
you gotta,
you've got to always try to look younger.
You got to do all this shit.
He's fucking women bench like that.
That doesn't happen to guys too.
You know what I mean?
Like if you go bald,
that doesn't affect the fucking parts you get off for.
So I as usual,
my cunty way rather than giving into that and getting the hair plugs and fucking
trying to a,
you know,
do whatever I steer into my ites keep myself looking good.
But it's just like I'm willing to lose whatever I'm going to lose to not come
out the other side with the fucking ant leg.
Caterpillar hairs coming out of the top of my head and fucking know face yanked
back and shit.
I'll tell you what's fucked up dude.
It's being in this business long enough.
You know you're going to see it right now at 40.
Yeah.
Which you're going to see is you're going to see,
you're going to see the first few people that you start out with go crazy.
Someone's going to go legit crazy.
Uh,
someone's going to quit.
It's weird when they quit at forties are fucked up one for people where they
just,
cause people start panicking.
If they don't have something going on,
they're going like,
this is my last port hole to get out of this shit and,
and actually have a legit career because I have this 20 year gap now in my
fucking resume that I went out and I,
I told jokes and shit and,
and then you'll see the other people that just doubled down.
They got nothing going on,
and then they start getting a little botox.
Uh,
you know,
the shoe Polish is going into the fuck and they start throwing hail Mary's.
Yeah.
No,
it's not.
I have males at this point,
but there's definitely the throwing the hook and ladder up.
Just definitely a halfback option.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
All of a sudden they throw in the fact that fake punt.
Yeah.
Your fake cards coming out right on this,
this,
this time.
So it's scary,
man.
The thing is,
the thing is,
is when I was,
I might say we were talking about,
but we would,
you know,
the business thing that I was talking to you about,
how you carry yourself in this fucking business,
right,
is there's that thing where you got to want it,
but you can't chase it.
You have to really believe in what it is that you're doing.
And then stick to that with this weird thing where you have to be flexible if,
if,
if what you're doing isn't working,
but if you,
you know,
if you're not hurting anybody,
you're not being malicious and you really have this fucking thing that you want
to do,
you have to stay on that thing.
And when people tell you no,
you don't take it personal,
but then you don't keep chasing them.
When they say no to you,
you keep doing your thing,
you keep fucking killing and all of a sudden they start hearing about you,
then they come to you and then it's everything that they said before.
It's water under the bridge and you have to let it go.
You can't ever do that.
A mother fucking you fucking said no to me back in 96 because they're not going
to remember it.
No.
And it's not.
And you're just going to come off and look like a fucking I insecure asshole.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I remember what you said to me like five years ago.
I had just moved into the house upstate and I go,
uh,
I remember I want it to get to tonight show.
I wanted to get something and um,
why the fuck are you auditioning for that gonna be like,
they're going to hear about you and then they're going to want you.
And I'm,
I literally thought when I got off the phone,
I'm like,
nothing can,
you're delusional.
You've been in the business longer than me,
but I'm going like bills 10 years ahead of me.
Like,
what's he talking about?
It's easy for him to say.
Right.
You know,
he's not an angry way,
but just like he,
I'm trying to get something like he's there,
you know what,
I'm trying to get something and then like sure enough,
like last year I did this monster set at Gotham and the booker of the tonight
show and he was just like a,
hey dude,
I don't know.
Yeah,
just send me like whatever I need.
And you know,
obviously I want to work on it.
This year and time went by,
I was working on the special side.
It didn't happen the way I want it to yet.
But he just goes,
yeah,
send me so well,
and it was just weird how he did kind of say,
I don't even need a tape.
We'll just let me know,
send a transcript that like tell me.
And I was literally like,
Oh my God,
that does happen.
Yeah,
but don't do it.
I chased,
I,
you know,
I chased it right up til about 2001 2002 and that's when I said fuck this.
But I did the whole thing when it was like whatever the look was,
I tried to have the look,
you know the fucking goatee,
you know this is,
I got old standup clips and everybody had to go t so I grew a fucking goatee.
I had like a,
you know,
it's funny now is now people will look at those things and they'll make comments
like they figured it out,
which is one of the things that I like,
like literally people listening right now.
You guys are ruining so much shit that you could fucking,
you know,
I don't know.
Like I,
I saw there was something on Twitter today was like check it all these cool
clips of people hanging out in Hollywood and all these fucking amazing parties
and shit.
Uh,
that no longer happened cause social media ruined it.
And,
and it's just like,
and I know everybody,
oh boohoo the,
they can't fucking hang out who had did for getting food and he blows,
it pulls.
It's just like,
dude,
I read when I came in the business like that's all you wanted to hear all those
stories about so and so going to the playboy mansion,
all these crazy fucking parties and all of that type of shit.
And the thing was was they were fun and now everybody's sitting there acting
like every fucking party.
There was some sort of like,
I dunno what me too thing that happened and everybody just had their fucking
dick out and shit.
And it's just like,
it's just this,
it,
it was a total fucking overcorrection now and I'm a tell you something right
now.
People are going to run from this shit.
The way they,
if the AllSeen for awhile they were acting like the alt scene was going to bury
like comedy clubs and then that just ended up fizzling out.
Now comedy clubs are thriving,
thriving and now all those students are slithering back into the comedy clubs
and it's just like all of that shit like they,
any sort of like extreme thing like that it can't sustain itself.
It just eventually what happens is it's not,
it goes away and tears.
Well it levels out cause right now like the behavior that was wrong,
it's going to be reported from here on out but now that just go in like that
sect,
that junk that I do on my act,
it's like now where there's somebody did something or not,
somebody has to get in trouble like they have to throw a body on the fire every
four to six weeks just to keep it in the news,
which I have a theory.
I think what's going to happen is I think with the whole me too thing and
everything,
I think what's going to make it die down and,
and I could be wrong,
but I think things are going to start coming out about females that did stuff.
Ah No,
that,
that that's,
that's a fucking pipe dream because shit has and nothing happens to them.
It's just why you teddy?
Actually,
you know what,
that nick cannon yeah.
That nick can't think they were all doing.
Why are you being so petty nick?
It's still is the guy's fault.
Where if somebody fucking did that to a gut,
if those were all guys,
nick has looking out for his friend and he just something,
if he just said,
hey man,
if I don't want to do this,
cause I don't want to get the people that he said in John.
Of course all of their tweets that I read were clearly them joking around.
That's it.
They're all jokes that they're all just at the point is,
it's all joke Kevin Hart's did as he was joking.
It was 10 years ago.
It was in his standup back and he's a comedian.
Yeah.
And they're acting like they heard him say this at like at a party with no set
up and punch on it.
I don't want to keep bringing this up because I don't want to attend to keep
mulching that over cause I'm sure he wants to fucking move on from it.
But it,
it is like this.
No,
it's just this,
this fucking thing that where everybody's go to.
Uh,
they get loud talk.
They get that fucking Guy John Legend's shit because when he took a pit and his,
he wrote music for that Dude's movie and it's like w what?
He's supposed to be standing in his shower to be knowing what the fuck he's
doing.
Yeah.
Like you don't know what somebody has done if you went to their party and years
earlier,
you don't know.
Yeah.
I might as well as I know you.
I don't know what you do.
Well,
I mean,
I call it,
we call it y'all are enough to bitch.
I know,
but you start like you don't know what point would you ever call me?
I'm gonna say a pill.
You wouldn't believe this man.
One time I took my deck out and I was blocking this door.
You would never tell me that.
But the thing is is I never did that.
But that's what I'm saying.
I shouldn't have said.
But if you knew somebody like that then it'd be like,
how could you have been friends with this guy?
It's like he had fucking tell me that shit.
Yeah.
People who are friends with people at work and the finds out there like a
fucking serial killer.
How could you take a picture with this guy?
He had already murdered 40 people.
It's like,
well he wasn't bringing that up when we were fucking hanging around the water
cooler.
Yeah.
You know to man,
like I feel like a lot of these head coaches,
we were talking about it before,
like you've got 53 man roster and you love him and one of them does something
and then they're like this piece of shit new and it's like,
you know,
it's totally,
yeah.
That becomes,
that then becomes at,
and then all of a sudden it's like this program is corrupt and everything,
like everybody knew and everybody,
everybody knew and everybody knows,
dude,
I remember,
I'm not gonna say names,
but one comic got in trouble and this guy tried to suggest that the entire
comedy club all got together and protected this guy.
And I almost did a spit take.
It's like the second that guy got in trouble,
all anybody underneath him was thinking is great.
Now I can get his spots.
I mean,
they just don't,
and it's always people who aren't in the fucking business.
It's just,
they don't understand how fucking cutthroat this business,
this business is.
Fuck,
I actually,
it's no nuts.
No different than I imagine if you were in the oil industry,
you know,
if you're on Wall Street,
just all of it,
when you're going for something that in the end,
at least back in the day,
you're going to have a yacht dude.
And there's going to be models on it,
like your fantasy when you're in your 20s,
like the shit that people are,
uh,
are willing to do.
Dude.
I remember after I did my second show ever,
I in New York City,
I crushed and I walked off and I literally was like,
dude,
I'm going to be in.
I'm like,
I'm going to be,
he started thinking,
you're like,
oh my God.
Cause you're like nobody could do,
you don't realize that there's other people out there.
You know when you first started doing it like this,
I'm going to be a fucking,
you know,
you can come in a business.
The first thing everybody thinks is I'm going to win an Oscar.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna have a fucking special and all that type of shit.
And then once,
when I,
what I liked about this business of in the last 10 years is I've actually
figured out where I want to be in it.
So any of that shit I would love to still happen or whatever.
But like,
it's just like if I could just traveling,
we're fucking Warsaw right now.
Like I just looked out there and I'm looking at this shit,
I can't fucking believe I'm here.
I can already tell this is going to be like Budapest where I remember we were
walking around Budapest yesterday.
I was like,
Paul,
I was just,
I liked this placement and these people are fucking cool.
And I got that vibe from the dude who drove was over here.
He was funny.
Estonia when I saw the guy and he was like,
okay.
And I was like,
this might not go the same.
And then when I got to Budapest and that woman was like,
oh here.
And she said,
my mother in law and if your throat hurts,
take this.
And all of a sudden I was like,
oh,
it's going to be great.
I got the same vibe here.
How funny is it that I saw like a Kia motors building and a fortnight poster,
which made me think of my son and I'm going to think it'd be great here,
you know,
but I will tell you this,
Bill,
I noticed this,
um,
I told you we were on a train from Munich to Frankfurt and I just started
watching people,
you know,
and people are the same.
Like I saw these 80 year old woman and they gave little candies out in the thing
and she took whatever her daughter or whoever did it and I saw her get her purse
and opened a person like my grandmother used to do with cookies.
My grandmother was like,
I don't know if it was from when she grew up cause she came here.
My grandmother came to the United States,
10 years old from Sicily,
didn't speak a lick of English,
would like go to a park and learn English that way at 10 years old,
oh my God,
she was,
she came at 10 years old,
a rest her soul.
She died.
I think she died at 80 80 in mid eighties so she probably,
I need a year.
I'm trying to do the math and thrown out yet.
When she tried to do the year,
when she painted,
she dialed do it for you.
She passed I believe in o nine oh nine [inaudible].
So that's like 1929 she probably came in the twenties 29 no wait,
no.
Is that 29 was that 91939495969 yeah,
it'd be 19 to 19 right.
So she got here,
let's say 1920 New York City depressions hang years old,
never spoke a lick of English.
And then she did this thing where like when we would go out,
she would go,
hey,
if they take those cookies and I'd be like grandma,
she would literally take two cookies that were that wrap 'em and Napkins and put
her in bed.
But still just that depression era shit.
So I saw this German woman do it and then I saw like the little kids and I saw
little girls from Germany on their phone.
Like it's all the same shit.
Yeah.
You know,
I'll talk about a fight with my wife and the jury,
even the journey cause ah,
they get it.
Everybody's the same human beings that that's what this trip has shown me is
that human beings are really all the same in a way,
which is now your bad ones.
This,
this will change how you then view foreign policy.
And when this,
when they're sitting there,
you know,
trying to make,
I still want the wall.
I don't want those atoms.
Calm Kid.
No,
but I know,
but uh,
I,
yeah,
it makes you think like,
oh well you know,
no,
but this shit where they sit there and they,
oh you know what I like your idea of,
of say the Middle East and stuff like that.
It just changes your life.
Cause there's that grandmother there,
there's the variety there,
there's the me there and then what you have is the lunatics at the top and they
just get everybody all fucking stirred up beneath them that these fucking people
are going to come over here and they're going to do this,
they're going to do that and all of this shit.
So I don't know.
You know,
it's fucking
hilarious about that.
That whole fucking Trump thing with the wall is,
I didn't realize there's there,
they're already really,
basically there's a wall there.
There's some areas where an area,
he's trying to get the area of the south that doesn't have as much,
which they're saying is doing stuff.
But he doubled down so much on it that that's why he's not,
it's like this is the thing,
like I don't think either side's going to back down.
No.
Because the Democrats can't back down and he's just getting up and walking out.
A guide that prideful that tweets late at night at celebrities that don't
matter.
Calls Single Comedians' names out as the present United States.
That guy that said we're getting the wall done and doubled down and promised his
thing.
He can't.
Yeah.
I can't tell if he's like,
uh,
not used to hearing.
No.
If it's insecurity,
like I'm not a psychologist,
but however he is made up,
um,
is,
is he's,
he isn't going to back down.
I love that tweet that you show share demands.
We'll just say share what?
Oh yeah,
I saw,
what was the word that they install all these headlines on the phone.
Um,
shared demands,
shared demands that Polosi don't die on top hill tops to shut down and don't
die.
Live share demands.
It's shared a man.
Yeah,
the pops,
the singer,
the,
the wetlands.
It well shared demands that this politician doesn't listen to.
This reality TV star that is now president,
like that's where the fuck were at.
Bill,
do not have funny.
The headline is shared demands.
Well,
what's funny is Trump's been presence is so fucking long that you forget that
this is the guy from the apprentice.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's bad.
You know,
I just liked it.
Now people are finally being able to kind of question financially what the fuck
we're doing over in Iraq because that is the big fucking thing.
And that is not,
that is not liberal or conservative.
That is just black and white dude.
Where it's just like how the fuck like to hear your kids,
kids,
kids are still gonna be paying that fucking tab.
It's,
you know,
and I think that they should fucking investigate those corporations that has
made zillions of dollars off of this.
W I think of the ones that are prolonging whatever the fuck it is we're still
doing there.
Um,
I dunno,
I mean,
I don't know enough about it,
but I,
I do,
I do know how to balance a fucking checkbook.
And I do see money coming in versus money going out assets.
And Liabilities and there is,
there is no other fucking business where you wouldn't,
you wouldn't right now just be completely fucked.
That's another funny fucking thing about him wanting to build this wall.
It's like with what money?
Yeah.
Cause they're gonna be like,
well that's going to create jobs and blah blah blah.
Yeah,
but then you still have to pay for the fucking wall.
And He fucked up man.
He fucked up dude by saying Mexico is going to pay for it and now American
taxpayers are gonna pay for it.
It's,
it's fucked up.
But uh,
talking about money,
you know,
he didn't because nobody's
going to remember that.
And all people do is like getting people who are for Trump to admit that this,
this financially doesn't make sense or what have,
we don't have the money or whatever the fuck it is.
It's literally trying to get somebody who's like a die hard whatever fan to
admit that that bullshit call that went your way was actually a bullshit call.
Like I would say like last,
not this past season,
the season before when that steel or click clearly caught the ball against the
patriots clearly caught a fucking touchdown and they called it back.
Now the amount of patriots fans,
I'll throw my own friends under the bus with the amount of them that would have
to be,
they would dove clearly he didn't make a football move rule is the rule.
Yeah,
yeah.
They would say that,
but it's just like,
you know,
I'm one of those guys all the way along.
The line was saying the Tuck rule is,
it's a stupid rule.
I understand that they wanted to have clarification or whatever,
but it's just at the end of the day it's like,
dude,
he had the guy slapped it out of his fucking hands and fell on it.
It's a fumble.
The fucking game is over the top row.
I remember Tom Brady being like,
hey man,
that's the fucking tucked role.
It's just like whatever,
but like trying to get people politically.
I see kids to look at people like trying to get,
like most of my friends are liberals trying to get them to see things about the
Clintons or the Obama's or whatever.
They just think,
oh,
but they did.
The best they'll say is they're not as bad as Bush than not as bad as Trump.
It's just like they always just steer it into this fucking argument where it's
just like,
you know,
if this guy is really a man of the people and he's really such a great guy,
why are his first two speaking engagements with two of the biggest fucking banks
out there when all of these people are upside down in their houses because of
these fucking cons?
Because at the end of the day,
they're getting paid by the same guys.
They got their faces in the fucking pig trough and this is too big for this
podcast.
I don't know why we're talking about this.
Maybe it's not going to spend the money about spending money.
You can balance a budget.
I mean you can balance.
You want to know what though?
I'm not good at it now.
I'm getting better.
I'm getting pell told me,
Paul told me cause his special did so well and now he's selling tickets.
He goes,
Bill,
I'm not going to lie to you.
I'm going to go through,
I'm going to go through a fur coat face.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't do that.
I actually think that that's too much.
I do think of for call.
It's a little ridiculous.
I do.
I don't know you like you liked one.
Will that fighter came in when he goes,
this is fucking polar bear.
The Guy,
he looks like the Burger King Guy.
The fucking,
he's got the super fast.
What's his name or the Irish guy?
Yeah.
Notorious Conor.
Conor McGregor.
Yeah.
He came out with like a white one and he just started walking,
but he did it like no shirt chain underneath.
Like that guy.
That guy's not only one of the best fighters in the world and he could just shit
talking.
He's up.
Maybe take five.
He could be a great standup comedian.
So yes.
Yeah,
I think kind of immigrant,
but he's shit talking.
I put them top five.
He's,
he's at wrestler level.
I love that one.
One time when he was doing to promote promotion it,
oh,
you'll do fucking not that.
My favorite one was when,
when he goes,
uh,
this guy's tried to give him shit and he just turns around and goes,
oh,
the fuck are you?
Who the fuck is this guy?
And even the guy started laughing and be like,
yeah,
I know.
Nobody knows who I am.
I was trying to get famous off of you.
He had all of them laughing.
I remember Rhonda Rousey was another thing.
He goes,
Ooh,
Ooh to focus this guy.
I love what he goes,
Yo do nothing.
And he gets,
he gets into it.
Oh He's,
he's,
he's on there man.
He's up there with that Lego.
But I will tell you this too.
I know he was going to,
I told you I heard things from people,
but when he was talking that extra shit,
somebody goes,
dude,
this is rocky three.
When that guy beat him,
like it seemed like he,
what does well,
because I feel like right now what he's trying to do,
cause too,
those guys are all pieces of me.
Yeah.
So what he's doing right now is I think he's realized that.
So he's trying to get on the other side where it's just like,
all right,
how the fuck can I get the most amount of money without getting my brains
beaten?
And so he took all that money to fight like Mayweather.
It's kind of like in the porn industry,
we're after a while they're like,
fuck this.
I'm starting my own website.
Yeah.
You know,
if I'm going to take all these hits,
man,
I'm fucking make it.
The money's coming to me.
Right.
Probably a fucked up analogy.
They can all these shots taken all these shots to the face,
man.
I'm going to fucking stop milk that God.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's exactly it.
All right.
I got to read a couple of advertising and then we're done.
Hey,
do you have any or club dates or anything that you've got a ton,
man,
I've got a ton.
I'm going to be a February through July.
All kinds of dates.
I believe my,
uh,
late February date data,
helium and buffalo tickets are on sale now,
but I have a bunch of dates.
So I was going to love about you.
What's your website?
You don't,
yeah.
Yeah,
it does.
Sounds,
it sounds right now,
uh,
if you go to the,
it's all done.
The website's new Paul [inaudible] dot com Vir.
The show's page has all the dates from now through 19 and more being added.
Yes.
And I can tell you that when we were at Gotham,
uh,
oh yeah.
Uh,
what was it?
A month ago or so I went and I did a show for the Mozillas.
I love those guys.
And they,
uh,
they were nice enough after we did the Gig in New York,
the month before they had the after party at the cake boss make the cake.
They just the best guys ever.
Um,
Steve and Chris.
So I was like,
I'm uncombed back.
I'll do a night.
So he did a night and you were on stage in front of me and you didn't know that
Seinfeld was coming down?
No.
Yeah.
So we were having him stretch and pulse thinking.
Why do they keep having me do more time bills in the room?
And I watched you do like 30,
35 minutes and you will refund and you were fucking around.
And I was just like,
wow man,
this guy's like the legit headliner and I'm telling you dude,
hours are going to come easy.
Much easier for you then then somebody who like is like a joke writer,
which is why I love joke writers cause it's like,
like how hard,
much harder it is for them.
But you're like a storyteller.
You are fucking with the crowd.
I mean I was like,
uh,
I was really like you,
you came into your own dude.
So definitely check Paul out.
Oh,
thanks a lot bill.
Well,
you know you've always been a Robin hood.
Everybody,
my one and only read here,
Robin Hood is an investing app that lets you buy and sell stocks,
ETFs,
options and Cryptos all commission free.
I have no idea when any of that means they strive to make financial service
services work for everyone,
not just the wealthy,
not intimidating wave for stock market,
uh,
non-intimidating way for stock market newcomers to invest for the first time
with true confidence,
simple and intuitive.
Clear design with data presented in an easy to digest way.
Costs Slash no commission fees.
Okay?
Does that make sense to you?
You just said cost.
No cost fees,
no commission fees.
Is that what that means?
Anyways,
I lost you.
You're looking at your phone here.
Other brokerage charges are up to $10 for every trade.
I love it.
He said,
no,
no.
And he kept looking at your phone.
But Robin Hood doesn't charge commission fees,
trade stocks,
and keep all of your profits easy to understand.
Charts and market
data.
Place a trade and just four taps on your smartphone.
Yeah.
Can you tell her I don't.
I don't live in this world at all.
I can barely even read this.
Robin Hood Web Platform also lets you view stock collections,
100 most popular sectors like entertainment and social media and curated
categories like female CEOs.
Ah,
uh,
um,
and analyze how about good CEO and analyze ratings to buy slash hold slash sell
for every stock.
Learn how to invest as you build your portfolio.
Discover new.
How about redheaded CEOs?
He got any of those fucking companies.
Discover bald,
redheaded male CEOs.
Discover new stops and trade.
Favorite companies with personalized news feeds,
custom notifications for price movements so you never miss the right moment to
invest.
Robin Hood is giving listeners a free stock like apple,
Ford or sprint to help you build your portfolio.
Sign up at Bill [inaudible] Dot Robin hood.com.
That's Bill Bird Dot Robin hood.com.
Uh,
do you render that shit?
Check it out.
All right,
that's the podcast.
Enjoy the music here.
And A,
there'll be a half hour bonus material from a old school throwback Thursday
afternoon just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
All right,
Paul,
a stream that,
yeah,
stream the special.
Still streaming a,
I'll say this,
comedy central broke their online records.
Please check it out.
Subscribe to the comedy Central App and you could get the special,
we're going to be putting out more clips and which what this website is it
comedy central comedy central,
not competence.
Also you could get it right from my website at [inaudible] dot com but if you go
to comedy central.com and you,
you could uh,
or,
uh,
subscribe to the APP and you could see the special there and check out
[inaudible] dot com for the new dates.
The beautiful.
All right.
Have a great weekend.
You can't send a Monday.
Might be a little bit late because
codes are,
unless we a reportable in Vienna,
but I'll be coming back I think flying back Monday,
which might be your Sunday because it was so far ahead.
I Dunno.
All right,
I'll see.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's built bar and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
January 10th,
2011.
How are Ya?
Hello?
It's me.
Why is that song in my head?
Lionel Richie.
There's a good looking fellow.
Huh?
That was one weird looking son of a bitch,
wasn't it?
You know,
with his,
his Jheri curl,
he had a Jerry curl,
a mullet and an afro all at the same time.
Three of a two out of three of the worst fucking haircuts ever.
I think the Afro was cool if you were in the Aba.
Other than that,
it was probably a,
just another reason for racist to not get along.
You know,
you sit there,
you're trying to be open minded.
You're write a fucking sporting event or maybe at a movie theater and some guy
comes walking in with a big doctor,
j Afro,
you know,
it doesn't have the decency to put that Frederick Douglass part on the side.
So maybe you could look down as part and see a little bit of jaws,
part two or whatever the fuck was coming out when people had hair like that and
what it creates
animosity.
That's what it is.
Everybody thinks it's said slavery stuff.
They think it's the Holocaust.
That's not what it is.
It's the haircuts people.
That's why people don't get along.
You know,
you look at other people's hair cuts,
it EOA kind of.
People will get haircuts like that,
you know?
And then there's some little psycho in the corner with greasy hair in a weird
mustache and the shit starts.
That's how it goes down.
People.
He might be sitting there right now.
Go cheap bill.
That was really fucking ignorant.
Don't you watch the history channel?
As a matter of fact,
I do.
I do watch the history channel.
Thank you very much for not asking me and allowing me to create your question in
my head.
I do watch the history channel and there's,
there's no history left on that channel.
All they show is pawn shop on that shit.
I don't know what the fuck is on that.
You know,
it's just become like every other channel.
I was reading something today where they were doing a mini series on the
Kennedys.
I a good shade a bridge and,
uh,
am I really going to do a hacky Ted Kennedy?
I think I've got to,
yeah.
Joe,
we went down to the bottom of the logo,
add a,
I took a deep breath.
I finger fucked her a couple of more times,
left her in the car and swam to the surface.
Actually the size of my head maybe be so buoyant.
I just sort of floated unconsciously,
your honor.
Uh,
yeah.
So they had a mini series about the,
uh,
the Kennedys and they canceled it.
They canceled it yet for some reason,
uh,
evidentaly if you have a bunch of shit in a storage shed,
they want to go down and film it.
Um,
was that a little social commentary?
Is that what I did?
Two minutes and 49 seconds into the podcast.
Did I really just do some sort of a,
what is the state of the history channel commentary?
I think I did.
Um,
okay.
Well I have an announcement to make and it's with heavy heart that I have to
tell you that my three week vacation is over,
you know,
uh,
yeah,
it's back to the goddamn grind.
And I know a lot of you right now going three weeks,
dude,
I get fucking two weeks for the year.
Well,
you know what?
That's your fault.
All right?
You pick that career.
It's a free God damn country.
Go write some fucking jokes.
You can't,
maybe then you,
you could take a three week vacation and buy vacation.
What I meant is,
uh,
I,
I didn't have to get on a plane.
I didn't have to go to any airports for three weeks was awesome.
I was actually hanging out with some people a the other day and uh,
they weren't Comedians,
but they traveled a lot and we just sat around talking about different airports
and that blew my mind how much I knew about all these airports and places where
you could get something decent to eat and buy decent.
Of course,
I mean by airport standards,
you know,
I know whenever I land in Dallas,
I'm going to come down that fucking escalator for,
for my connecting flight.
And there's that awful Mexican restaurant that's right there.
And every time I go in there because I'm hungry and I hope against hope that
they're going to have the real cheese and not that cheese whiz.
You know,
that cheese come that they put on the burritos and every time I order a fucking
Burrito,
I said,
hey,
listen,
this Burrito,
does it have the real cheese or does it have that nuclear waste cheese with
stuff?
And the waitress never knows,
you know,
because who's getting home?
If you're a waitress at an airport,
you don't give a fuck,
you know?
I don't know.
Let me go in and ask the sheriff.
Then they go in and they come back.
So what's the verdict there?
Uh,
what's a good Texas fucking nine?
Tacy.
You what's,
what's the verdict there,
sweetheart?
Is it the,
do you have the real cheese?
We certainly doubt nodding the head.
You know,
mind fucking,
you're like,
you've got to get an,
you know,
nodding up north means yes.
Down South they could mean yes or fuck no.
Why?
We most certainly do not.
We absolutely doubt,
ah,
with your big fucking,
those big fucking Texarkana,
those Oklahoma,
that fucking huge white girl face that,
that Hugh Hefner loves.
He loves those girls.
Those big panhandle faces.
Huge fucking heads.
Texas,
Oklahoma,
Arkansas,
white girls got the biggest rounders fucking heads I've ever seen in my life.
Jesus fucking Christ.
They played football.
You couldn't get in my helmet.
You'd have,
you'd have to custom make helmets for the beautiful bodies,
you know,
big Vanilla titties,
Huh?
That's right.
Big Vanilla.
Titties.
I,
yeah.
Big Banella Teddy's,
they got the,
you know,
the stars at night are big and bright.
Just like my big fucking head,
you know,
if I'd have slapped the shit out of any woman,
I don't,
I think I can't.
Yeah,
I think it'd be what some chick from fucking Texarkana,
Oklahoma,
you know,
just get a big 12 ounce glove,
right.
Boxing Glove,
big fruit card of a fucking head.
Um,
all right.
Speaking of which,
I will be in Addison,
Texas,
now that I've trashed,
you're women,
you're women.
Okay.
I'm going to be there the last weekend,
uh,
in,
in January.
So if you get a chance,
you know,
you put on your best pair of boots.
Is that what you guys do out there in Dallas?
Why am I shitting on this is the second week in a row I've shit on people in
the,
in the Greater Dallas area.
Um,
and I still have the audacity to think that I'm going to sell tickets down
there.
Jesus Christ.
Is this the Chinese Year of arrogance?
Because that's what I'm feeling.
Um,
anyways,
so two more weeks of no Busan and I've made my 100 days,
100 days.
I think about you in a hundred ways.
What song was that?
Was that a Jane's addiction song or was that when they were porno for Pyros?
Pyros.
Huh?
Was that Tahitian Moon?
Is that what I was just singing there?
What was it,
Bali in my eyes.
Um,
I,
my the,
uh,
the,
is it anybody else in the podcast?
I'm a,
I am.
I like the only person who ever bought that CD.
The second porno for Pyros.
I like Bali,
that song.
Bali.
I don't like the weird high pitch singing that Perry Farrell does in the
beginning of it,
but I really liked the sound of the guitar just in case you were wondering if
you would just sit in there going,
you know,
I wonder what bill thinks about that obscure track.
What does it,
the fucking last song,
second side
fucking gives a shit.
All right,
what the hell am I talking about?
Okay,
let's,
let's talk about something in sports that really fucking bothered me this
weekend.
Uh,
I was watching the Bruins Canadians game.
Okay.
Pay horrific loss for the Bruins.
We were up to the north and then we led up to fucking goals and then right in
the end and the lost in overtime.
Well this is what pisses me off about the fucking Canadians is uh,
the Canadians are sort of like,
they're like math and I'm Matthew mcconaughey Hayes character in dazed and
confused.
Remember that guy?
The 26 year old guy's still hanging out at high school.
Where in his fucking Letterman jacket asking where the parties are.
That's what they are like.
They are a still the most successful NHL franchise in the history of hockey,
but they have not dominated the league since pre Gretzky.
We'll talk in 1979 we're talking Jimmy Carter in office.
Alright.
We're talking about the,
the AMC Pacer being a viable option for a car or the future.
I know,
I just realized because I drive a Prius that I bet if me live my was my age in
1979,
I would have bought it.
I would've bought a pacer.
I really just learned that about myself.
It makes me feel bad.
So anyways,
um,
just to give you a little bit of history between the Bruins and the Canadians.
The Canadians kicked the shit out of the Bruins for a good 50 fucking years.
Alright.
Dominated the league.
We met him in the finals seven times and we never beat him.
And every time we went up to the,
to the Montreal forum,
they always beat us.
And it was like this Hex,
we just couldn't beat it.
Right.
And this is the weirdest jinx in sports
because in 1987,
88 we finally went up to the Montreal forum.
We finally had a better fucking team.
Well,
a couple of times we had a better team,
but we would still lose.
But we finally had a better team and we fucking feed them.
Right?
It's over.
The fucking Hex is over.
Oh,
thank God.
Right?
Just for,
for better measure.
Two years later we beat them again in the fucking playoffs,
you know,
and then over the next 20 years,
we pretty much went tit for tat and the playoffs.
Okay.
Play offs.
And two years ago,
we beat Montreal every fucking game in the regular season and then we swept them
in the playoffs,
the final two games in their own building.
Okay.
But for some fucking reason they still always talk about this fucking Hex,
like it's still going on.
I for the life of me,
could somebody hockey fan please fucking explain it and don't even say it's
because the Bruins having won a cup,
because we did during that 50 year fucking drought,
we won in [inaudible] 70 and we wanted 72
that would be like if the red sox won it in [inaudible] 70 and [inaudible] 72
when you're still talking about the curse of the babe,
I don't know what this fucking curse is.
Is it because we haven't beaten them in the finals ever?
We can't.
They realigned the divisions.
We've played them in the playoffs.
We've beaten since 87 we're pretty much 50 50 against them.
I don't fucking understand.
I understand it when Dan Shaughnessy says something because Dan Shaughnessy like
if an old 80 like an 80 year old woman became a sports writer,
she would be Dan Shaughnessy because Dan Shaughnessy never talks about the game.
Dan Shaughnessy loves ghosts and Goblins and fucking urban myth.
He's everything about the fucking game.
He will talk about all of it.
Like he doesn't know shit about hockey.
Okay?
All right.
As he asked,
actually called for the end of the winter classic this week,
he said,
you know,
it's time to retire the winter classic.
This is,
this is,
this is what a more on this guys.
He talks about how the first fucking three years were awesome and how he stood
next to Bobby.
Your arguably the greatest player of all time,
you know,
if not top two,
if not top three,
if you're a cunt,
you know,
the fucking arguably greatest player of all time stands next to Dan Shaughnessy
when the,
the winter classic was at Fenway Park and he says to Shaughnessy,
this is what real hockey is.
This is what it is.
This is it,
this is,
this is it.
And it's,
it's,
it's most pure form.
This is how we all learned how to play.
All right?
And then this year,
just because you know,
one year that you're going to have bad weather,
it was kind of raining out in the ice,
wasn't good.
Shaughnessy says that they should cancel it.
He's such a fucking retard.
It's like Dan,
those first three years,
that's pond hockey in the middle of the winter.
What you saw in Pittsburgh is pond hockey at the beginning and the end of the
pond hockey season.
All right,
if you have a fucking played in,
in your life,
your dumb ass.
The second I saw that Pittsburgh Washington game and I saw the ice surface with
those puddles,
I immediately was taken back to my youth during the,
you know,
just to be getting when it was just cold enough to play hockey or you will come
into spring and what would you do?
You take big rock should throw them up in the fucking air,
see if they would go through the ice and then you'd send the fattest fucker.
You've added all your friends to walk out on the ice.
And if he didn't drown,
game on,
you'd go out there and you would skate,
you know,
and if you started losing,
you try to trip one of your friends into the big puddle,
so whatever.
So anyways,
so I want to know seriously,
okay,
now Montreal Canadien fans.
I'm not disrespecting you guys,
you guys,
you know,
other than the New York Yankees,
uh,
you're,
you're the most success.
You have the most championships.
All right?
And if I had to rate franchises,
I would say Yankees,
Lakers,
uh,
Canadians and then Celtics.
And I know a lot of Boston fans aren't going to like that,
but this,
this is why.
All right.
Yankees cause they got the most and they've won in every era.
Then I would go,
I would say I would go Lakers just because they've won 10 championships in the
last 30 years,
that know Canadians haven't,
Yankees haven't,
I mean,
that's fucking unheard of in the modern era with free agency.
Uh,
that,
that's,
that's fucking insane.
Um,
well,
so I guess I would put that maybe I would say,
okay,
well I don't know where to put the Lakers.
How about that?
I will put the Lakers is the best franchise at the last fucking 30 years without
a doubt.
Um,
okay.
And I can't remember what the fuck I said about the rest of the shit.
All right.
But I don't understand like what exactly has to happen?
How many fucking times to the Bruins have to beat the Canadians and the fucking
playoffs?
I don't get it.
And we've won.
We won two Stanley cups during.
I just,
I don't get it.
I absolutely,
I do not fucking understand why every time I watch the Canadians Bruins,
they have to bring up something that ended that fucking ended.
Jesus Christ.
Oh,
almost a quarter of,
a century ago.
The Canadians have not dominated the Bruins for any significant amount of time
since,
uh,
86 pre eight,
1986.
I Dunno if I got the Canadian feed.
I have no idea what,
but that is the most overrated fucking thing I've ever heard.
Overrated fucking thing I've ever heard.
And anytime the Canadians when like they did,
came back and won there,
there'll be,
like you say,
you see and,
but they'll,
they,
they'll ignore the fact that we swept them for a whole year and in the playoffs,
the final two games in their own fucking building.
You know,
how come the Red Sox,
how come their thing ended?
I don't,
I don't get it.
No,
other than w shouldn't,
shouldn't that,
that thing of continued the whole fucking thing doesn't make sense.
And it's just this classic a thing is a Boston sports fan,
which I'm,
I'm so fucking sick of is I can't stand,
first of all,
I don't believe in curses.
That whole Dan Shaughnessy old fucking lady thing where it's such a pussy way of
looking things where you literally take your hand off the wheel,
you have no control of your destiny because there's a Goddamn Gremlin under your
bed.
It's like,
isn't it really that aside,
in fact that Montreal was a tremendous fucking franchise back in the day.
All right.
As tremendous as they were,
the Bruins were horrific,
wasn't it?
That,
Eh,
you know,
Harry Sinden didn't embrace free agency and he resented fucking resented the
fact that players were now in control and he absolutely categorically fucking
refused to pay top dollar whether they were worth it or not.
Wasn't that,
wasn't that more likely than that?
There was some sort of fucking ghost floating around a fucking hockey arena.
I don't know.
So whatever.
So for the 900 fucking years in a row,
I got to watch a Bruins Canadians game.
And despite the fact that the Montreal Canadians are not a factor in the NHL
anymore,
they're in first place now.
But you know what I mean?
That they're not an elite franchise anymore.
They're just not.
And they haven't been.
Okay.
They haven't won a fucking cup since 93 it's over.
It's over.
Okay.
It's fucking over.
I mean,
I,
I don't,
I don't know.
I mean,
as a Celtics Fan,
I admit that it did.
It's,
it's over.
It,
it died when Len bias died with Len bias died.
It was fucking over and it hasn't come back just because we won one since then.
It hasn't come.
It's fucking over,
you know,
speaking of which,
I've actually started to watch a lot of hoop,
and I gotta tell you something.
When the fucking Boston Celtics,
I've never seen so many goddamn ace bandages in knee pads in my entire fucking
life.
I think they have the oldest legs in the NFL and the NBA,
every one of them is tape from the ankles up to their hips.
I don't think,
I really just don't see them winning it this year.
I don't,
I think that,
uh,
I think Miami Heat's going to do it.
I actually think they're going to do it.
They're,
they're,
they're much younger.
The fucking,
everybody's dressed like Marcus Haynes on the Goddamn Celtics.
Now he is an old reference for you.
Huh?
Markus Hanes.
Look it up.
People,
he was a,
the,
the magical fucking a,
the guy in the globe trotters
Boobie,
boobie.
Right.
And each slide around on the floor.
You know what black people bitch about fucking Hollywood and that type of shit.
Don't we do the white people,
you know,
for the,
the stereotypes and the awful roles which they've been given for decades in
Hollywood,
you know,
to white people get any sort of credit for being on the Washington generals and
just being absolute stooges.
You know what I mean?
Just going out there,
paid to lose,
paid to fall for the same fucking trick every goddamn night.
Just looking like absolute fucking buffoons.
Do we get any sort of a credit?
Can Can Spike Lee make a tragic film about white people who had played in the
Washington generals?
Anybody?
Can anybody back when we back me on that one?
Back me up people.
What's the deal?
Um,
how far did this fucking podcast down?
My 20 God damn minutes.
Alright,
so what is there to talk about you guys?
Uh,
what do you guys want to talk about?
I sound like a headline or right now who is run out of jokes and he's done an
hours worth of material in 20 minutes.
So now he's just going to try to fucking play with the crowd,
which I can't do because not here.
So why don't we read this,
uh,
this email under the provocative name corporate bullshit.
Uh,
Bill,
uh,
dear bill recently I had to return some items at the mall.
Uh,
it was the day after Christmas and I was with a girl.
I was dating,
uh,
with the girl that I was dating.
She wants to return some shoes.
So we went to the journey store with his shoes were bought.
Uh,
when she got to the counter to return the shoes,
the girl behind the counter asked her for her name,
address,
email,
and phone number.
Okay.
Oh my God.
The amount of fucking people who actually give out that information.
My girlfriend just gave the information over.
As soon as the girl asked for it,
we were leaving the store.
I remarked that I thought it was bullshit,
that she had to give away personal information to return a pair of shoes.
She said,
uh,
it was not a big deal,
but I didn't like it.
All right.
Why the fuck would you give somebody all that information and just in case
you're new to my podcast,
just say you can say no,
can I,
you know I,
I go out to buy shit all the time.
Can I have your phone number?
No,
I don't even say,
I don't even try to make it nice.
I just say no and then they go,
oh,
okay.
You know,
why do you feel like you got to give them their information?
You're trying to buy something.
I'm sorry I can't,
I can't show you this unless I get your information.
Well they go fuck yourself.
Abide somewhere else.
I don't even need it.
Anyways.
So anyways,
he goes,
next we go to American Eagle.
You guys hit all the hot spot,
Huh?
Then we went to Cinnabon.
Next we went to American Eagle where I had to return a shirt.
That was a gift.
It was a long line for returns.
Why'd you return the shirt and did it not fit or was it ugly as hell or was it
both?
As I was waiting in line,
one of the employees comes up to me with a clipboard with the little form to
fill out.
Now is anybody else kind of getting the prison camp vibe here?
You know,
they're standing in line to get processed and there's a guy coming up onto the
VAT.
Is Your name please?
Your phone number?
Uh,
I stopped the employee.
I stopped the employee and asked her why she needed this information and she
says that it was to verify my purchase.
How fucking dumb our people.
You're going to verify my purchase.
Well,
here's the sale slips there,
sweetheart.
This verifies it.
That's it.
I don't know what to tell you.
Why don't you and your clipboard?
Why don't you hold that clipboard between your little fucking beef curtains and
take a fucking walk down the street.
How about that?
How sweetheart,
it's there.
There's the reasons you use that type of language.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Huh?
How about I fucking grabbed that ponytail and just,
no,
let's,
let's let,
let,
let's keep it clean this week,
shall we?
People anyways,
she,
he goes before I could protest further.
She said that I could just put my name on it.
Oh,
on
the clipboard.
Okay.
When she walked away,
I pulled out the gift receipt Ppas said to my girlfriend,
oh,
here it is.
Yeah.
This is what verifies my purchase.
Exactly.
The clipboard employee wasn't as far as way as I thought she was in.
Heard me say,
did I read that wrong?
Get heard me say it's heard me say this.
And she began to explain further why I needed to give over the information.
This is the part of the email I hate.
He goes,
I apologized and told her.
I realized it wasn't her and that it was just her company's policy that she was
enforcing.
She walked away again.
I felt bad.
So the next time I saw her,
I apologize and said,
I realized that she was just doing her job,
but she ignored me.
She was probably pissed because it was the day after Christmas and I was causing
your grief,
but you could at least accept my apology.
You Bitch.
Um,
I love how you go from being totally liberal and seeing somebody fucking side of
it too,
being yeah,
man up,
you can't.
Um,
anyway,
I got up to the counter and there wasn't any further problems.
The guy at the register just took my name and didn't ask me for anything.
I felt as though I had a small victory against the big corporations.
Then this week I had to go back to the store to return a hat my girlfriend got.
Did you guys not make Christmas lists or all your relatives blind?
The seems to be a lot of,
uh,
returning of gifts.
This is hilarious.
You're returning a hat that your girlfriend got.
You Dude.
How horrific was that hat?
Can you please send me a picture of it before I,
if you took one before you returned it?
Okay.
Picture one of those,
uh,
plaid Charlie Chaplin Hat.
Um,
I had the receipt,
but again,
the girl at the register asked me for my address and phone number.
I said,
I didn't want to give that information to her.
Immediately panic sets in and her face and she says that I have to.
I said that I didn't have to the day after Christmas and I wasn't going to now,
good for you.
She calls over a coworker and they both get defensive and hold to the idea that
I have to give over my information in order to return a stupid hat.
Even though I had my receipt,
I asked why and they let me slide.
Why did the let me slide on this before and they maintained that I had,
I had to give them my name,
address and phone number,
so what did I do in the face of corporate opposition?
I caved and I gave it to him.
You Fuck Pussy?
Okay,
dupe.
The second you saw the panic on their face,
you knew that they were going to lose.
All right.
He goes,
I just don't get it,
Bill.
Why is a receipt not enough?
Nowadays it is enough.
They say they need our personal information to verify purchase then not,
dude,
they're not.
All right.
All of that shit.
All those little save,
you know you want to get when our discount store,
they're creating a file on you.
They figure out what you want to buy,
what they can market towards you,
and then they take that information and they sell it to other fucking companies.
Even though they say they're not going to,
they sell your information,
your information gets up on the Internet.
And that's why there's all these creepy websites out there right now that have
all this fucking information about you,
about,
you know,
how many siblings you have,
your brothers and sisters names.
They all use that information to fucking,
it's,
I'm telling you,
okay,
this don't give him your information.
You don't have to give him your information and people out there
who just have this fucking attitude towards these corporations just sitting
there going like,
wait,
you know what we do?
What do they get?
You mean as long as you're not doing anything wrong?
I mean,
what do I care if they know where I live?
What do I keep this fucking morons?
I don't even,
I have explained this shit till I'm blue in the face and then I always get these
emails from these people.
Um,
he just,
I don't know.
I can't,
if I said something the other day,
you know,
I sit there,
listen to,
I was sitting there,
I was listening to a sports radio,
you know,
cause I'm a deep thinker,
right.
And uh,
this,
this new guy got on sports radio out here in Los Angeles and you know,
he does what most people do when they have nothing to say,
which is they,
they just start,
they just go over the top arrogant.
You know what I mean?
Like he was talking about how he wanted to get some,
some sort of sports culture personality on the show,
but he doubted he could get them as a guest because the guest hated him.
And he goes,
you know,
cause I disagreed with them on some,
he talking to a coach and he was actually disagreeing with the,
with the fucking coach.
He's disagreeing with the guy and he goes,
you know what the problem is?
You know,
he goes,
look,
I'm,
I'm just like such a good debater.
I actually ended up like convincing myself of my own opinion.
You actually said that over the airwaves and I just sort of muttered to myself
that the confidence of morons is staggering.
You know what I mean?
Morons think they know everything.
That's,
that's what makes them fucking morons.
And like the emails,
like get with people who don't question this shit.
Um,
which is,
I don't know,
like last week when I went,
I went off on my little fucking rant there.
Just some of the fucking emails I get,
it's like people are sending me shit.
That kinda is backing up what I'm saying and then telling me that it sound like
I have tin foil on my fucking head,
which obviously I am out of my fucking mind on some level,
but I'm not out of my mind when I don't trust corporations and I don't trust
them when they say we're not going to do anything with this information.
The other day I was in cvs and I go to buy something and the lady asked me,
did I have a safe card?
And I said,
no.
She said,
do you want one?
And I said,
no.
And she goes,
well,
that's okay.
I'll just,
and she swiped the fucking thing anyways.
And I was like,
lady,
what did I just say to you now?
See if I use my credit card,
they'd have my,
yeah,
and then to match up to that fucking number and what the hell I just bought.
And just a little bit more information about me and my question to all you
people who have these,
this faith
in these corporations,
why does that person do that?
Why are they so hell bent on trying to make that corporation less money in that
moment?
They give me this card,
you know,
like everybody has those cards so you're not saving any fucking money.
It's just,
it's a big fucking shell game to make it seem,
oh look,
you're saving money.
What they're really doing.
Did I look at this hand over here is you're giving them all your personal
fucking information that they can then use to at the very least sell to other
corporations to increase junk mail and it also to a limit.
You're fucking level of privacy.
The fact that they can put all that shit up in the Goddamn Internet.
People have been sending me these random websites where they have like your name
and your address,
where you fucking live and all this type of shit.
It's like,
how do you think that they get all that information?
Do you think there's somebody sitting there with the phone book and just typing
all of this shit in?
I don't know.
I'll fuck it though.
If some,
what's what's what kills me.
If some fucking random creepy guy,
you know you're standing there waiting for the subway came up to you,
asks you what's your name,
your phone number and your address was,
would you give it to them?
No,
but for some reason you're inside of a fucking store and there's socks and
sweaters and somebody has a name tag.
Now all of a sudden you,
you,
you give them total fucking trust.
You're writing your mind.
So sir,
don't cave in.
All right,
all you get,
you just,
just say that's unacceptable.
That's unacceptable.
I want to speak to the manager what they're doing.
It's not legal yet.
It's not legal yet,
but I can guarantee you there's somebody lobbying for it that in Washington
there's some sort of fucking high powered lobbying group.
I swear to God is probably lobbying that from here on out.
We need to have a law that if you're going to return a hat,
you have to give us your name,
your address,
and your social security number.
Just so there's not another nine 11 could guaran fucking tee it.
So yeah,
you don't have to.
That's actually one of the highlights of my day.
What I do now is when they say,
do you have our little savy save card?
And I say,
no I don't.
Would you like one?
No,
I don't.
I then say,
and please don't swipe another one.
You know,
and then I tried to pay with cash.
I love cash.
Cash is fucking anonymous.
All you guys out there who was sitting there watching these commercials where
they make look like credit cards are so fucking easy.
You,
you're,
you're idiots.
If you're buying into exactly what they want you to buy into,
which is a cashless society so they can keep track of where you are at all
fucking times and every last fucking dime that you make so they can get their
greedy little fucking hands on it.
You're out of your mind and you're giving up an unbelievable amount of fucking
privacy by creating a paper trail.
Everywhere you go,
everywhere you go,
what you're doing,
where you're at,
you know,
and the Sea of morons who we're going to sit there and go,
Whoa,
have you doing anything wrong?
I mean,
I guess maybe,
maybe I'm a paranoid psycho.
You look at all these fucking idiots who do reality TV's and [inaudible] and
they let cameras come into their house and they don't seem to care about it.
Maybe,
uh,
maybe the average jackass doesn't give a ship at Sir for the love of God.
You know,
in the end he says,
I'm not crying conspiracy.
It's very plain to see what they're doing.
It's not malicious or evil.
Yes it is.
It is malicious and it is evil and it is a conspiracy.
They're conspiring to get everybody's information.
Find out what they buy,
and they're lying to you saying that they're not going to share the information.
It's everything that you're saying.
It's not.
It is a right and that's it.
That's two weeks in a row.
I'm on the soapbox.
See people,
don't you like it better when I talk about sports.
Um,
anyways,
let's talk about football this week.
You're going to hear me say something this week that I've never said before ever
on a podcast.
I feel bad for Peyton manning.
Peyton manning got fucked this week by his own Goddamn coaching staff.
Um,
he played a great God damn game when they needed a score,
he drove him right down the fucking field.
If that bomb caught that ball,
they were right in there.
And even still,
and by the way,
Anna,
Vinod Terry,
it's a shame that jets one the God damn game because that guy is the most money
kicker of all time.
I was actually joking with my buddy when I was watching the game.
Um,
I was saying that the most pussy ever gotten by a professional kicker has to be
Adam for Adam voluntary.
It's gotta be,
it's gotta be,
and I actually learned that there's no kicker in the NFL hall of fame and
there's no fucking way.
It's just a shame not cause I even that I hate the jets.
It's not,
it's a shame that the jets one that fucking game because
it,
people are going to forget that he actually hit that fucking 50 yard a man write
down the fucking middle,
right down the middle.
But,
uh,
I,
I was right there with Peyton manning when he was,
had his hands out when called when the fucking cults called Timeout with 29
seconds to go.
Can somebody explain why the fuck they did that?
And don't even say,
well dude point to relate to Jake,
we're going to kick a field goal.
And they wanted to make sure that what they'd have 17 seconds to get down the
fucking field.
There wasn't gonna be enough time.
There wasn't going to be enough time.
You add a second year quarterback who had,
who,
who fucking had that deer in the headlights look,
he was overthrown all his fucking receivers.
You take a timeout,
you give them a chance to gather himself for their coaches to give them the next
three plays so we can fucking relax.
And what comes to comes right out.
He hits a fucking 18 yard pass and that's the end of the game.
And when Peyton was sitting there with his hands out like,
what the fuck are we call a timeout for?
It was the one time I have,
I actually felt bad for that guy.
I just sat there and I've gone,
I think they are in the process of losing this fucking game.
Not It just giving the game away.
Um,
it was fucking brutal.
Absolutely brutal.
So there you go.
Peyton manning did not lose that game.
He fucking stepped it up.
He played a hell of a Goddamn game.
And I actually feel bad for the guy that he,
that he lost.
And if I'm going to be honest now that I think about it,
about five,
six years ago,
you know,
he drove his team down the field and their idiot kicker would talk shit about
Peyton choking in the playoffs.
He went on and he missed the fucking field goals.
So there's two years,
two losses.
I,
I won't,
I won't blame Peyton manning for all right.
There you go.
See that the could make trying to be a little more forgiving in a,
in this year.
And,
um,
and I realized this week too,
that I've been feeding into exactly what Rex Ryan wants,
which is people just talking about him.
Um,
you know,
what are the odds,
do you think he think he's going to say something outrageous this week?
Uh,
it's really like watching Madonna's career.
You know,
where you have a woman who,
uh,
has a mediocre voice and has made mediocre music for the last 30 fucking years.
Yet somehow,
eh,
whenever she wants to be as in the news.
And you know why?
Because she knows when to take her clam up.
All right?
She knows when to go on Letterman and say,
fuck 38 times during an interview.
You know when you really think about Madonna,
what does it have to do?
Oh Wow,
look how good shape she's in.
Did you see when she did the book and she fucking spread her legs yet?
Oh,
did you see when she said fuck on Letterman?
Did you see what she did?
The video and a fucking Jesus was black and then she kissed him.
Of course.
That's what you talk about.
What are you going to talk borderline so you're like,
I'm going to lose by by rarely,
30 year career off of that horse shit.
What's his face is doing the same thing.
He's doing the exact same fucking thing.
Dropped a bunch of f bombs during hard knocks.
That was his Letterman episode.
All right.
He put a wig on.
That was him showing his clam
and then then he made a controversial a video.
Other than that he lost the division.
Backed into the fucking playoffs.
Playoffs I,
yeah.
I don't know.
You know,
you don't even realize this week I didn't even know what the name of the coach
was for the Atlanta Falcons.
I given this guy no hype whatsoever.
Mike Smith,
I had actually actually had the look it up.
This is a guy who went 13 and three who actually has,
has actually has a franchise quarterback and Matt Ryan,
he actually has a franchise quarterback,
you know,
but it's not a New York.
So who gives a fuck,
right.
Um,
with that,
my predictions for the week,
um,
Berg Ravens,
I have no fucking idea.
Uh,
patriots jets,
I have no fucking idea,
but just for the simple fact,
I have no idea which defense to patriots are going to show up with.
You know,
I am not a guy if you realize that I'm not a guy who buys into hype,
that's why I've have not bought into rex Ryan for half a fucking second.
Uh,
that's why also when the Patriots won 45 to three,
I didn't go well there you go.
Cause I realize we also lost 28 to 14.
I also know that we suck against the run.
So I think if we're going to win,
I'll tell you,
if I'm the Patriots,
I gotta be taken.
I got to stop Lt.
No,
seriously,
we,
if we,
if we can stop the run and,
uh,
go up by a good 10,
14 fucking points and put Sanchez into a situation where he feels like he has to
make a play,
uh,
we're going to be,
eh,
we're going to be all right.
That's what we need to do.
And I have faith that we're going to fucking do that.
I hope for the love of fucking God,
because if we don't,
uh,
you're going to listen to the sounds of a blubbering jackass next week on this
fucking podcast.
Um,
and that is it.
So that's it.
I'm really hoping,
uh,
oh,
look at this.
Look at this.
I got some offers coming in.
Yeah.
We go where,
where am I going to be performing?
Oh,
by the way,
I'm actually in the process of,
uh,
of,
getting a Detroit and Milwaukee date.
I have not played in Detroit since I did the rich bitch tour way back in the day
with Charlie Murphy and a ashy Larry and I have not played Milwaukee ever.
I know I did a college in that area because a long time ago I went to a bucks
game.
Um,
but what else do I got going on here?
Of course I don't get the fucking Internet here.
My bedroom,
the hell's wrong with me.
I'm stepping up my life in 2011 people.
Um,
all right,
let's go with youtube videos for the week.
All right.
Um,
oh,
here's something.
I've been watching a lot of basketball lately and Kareem Abdul Jabbar always
gets credit for inventing the Sky Hook.
And uh,
I always took that as law and I was just like,
yeah,
the guy invented the sky hook.
Wow.
People must have been like,
what the fuck?
You know,
they went from the set shot to the,
you know,
the way they traditionally shoot now with the one hand,
the other hand guide the ball and then he comes out with that shit.
People must have just been like,
where the fuck did that come from?
And then I was looking at some old Celtics video and that was sort of a shot
that people already took in the 60s,
but they did it from their hip and it was one of the gayest looking shots you're
ever going to see.
You just sort of jumped in the air,
had one leg up in the air bent at the knee.
Like I don't think that there's a physical way to do that shot without going.
We as you throw it,
but uh,
he just saw he changed it where he didn't shoot it from the hip.
He just put it over his fucking head.
So there you go.
Um,
here's a nice conspiracy theory.
One from people in the,
I believe in Seattle,
you go to a Seahawks game,
they have a large beer and a small beer and the large beer is like a dollar 75
more if they come in two different glasses.
So somebody filled up a small glass with water and poured it into the large
glass in it,
filled it all the way up.
It was classic,
the small glasses,
a little fat one and the other one's nice and tall.
So you think you get more and you're not and they charge your next a dollar 25
a.
So we made a video of it.
Um,
what else?
What other videos do I have here?
Oh,
this is one from a new website.
Uh,
totally crap.
Totally crap.com.
They got a lot of good,
good videos and there's one there called five minute fight.
All of these by the way will be up on the m M podcast.com.
Um,
yeah.
And what else?
Oh,
this one is a,
a video also on a totally crap.com.
Uh,
and it's also an underrated and it says underrated ass whooping.
So many things would be salt if people would start their kids outright.
And the name of this video is old school ass whooping.
And uh,
I don't know how to describe this other than this father puts on a video camera.
He makes his kid telling me he's not going to be in a gang.
And he starts beating him with the belt and the kid tells his dad is not,
the gangs are bullshit.
He goes,
don't tell me,
tell it to the fucking camera.
And he continues to beat his ass with a belt.
It's a sad,
it's funny.
It's everything you want it to be.
And then there's another video that I saw right after that.
It's five minute fight and this fight is fucking hilarious.
There's two white kids,
they're calling each other bitch and they're calling each other the n word.
And I swear to God,
they might both throw 700 punches and I think they miss 698 each.
It's the classic thing.
We got two people who want to fight.
They don't know how to fight.
And all they know is they want to punch the person,
other person in the face,
but they don't want to get hit in the face.
So they won't commit to coming inside.
And they just sort of punching the atmosphere around the other guy's head.
Or as I like to say,
uh,
an NBA basketball fight.
You ever watch?
Oh,
NBA basketball players fight for the most part.
They pull their head behind their shoulders and then they,
they throw punches like they're trying to throw a fucking baseball from the
outfield to home plate.
Um,
all right.
I'm just really just giving information this week.
I don't feel like I'm fucking,
Oh,
here we go.
Nope.
That was from last week.
Oh,
for Christ's sake.
You Cook the shit out of me.
Where the hell am I here?
What the fuck is my underrated overrated for the week?
Oh,
overrated.
Underrated.
Here we go.
Overrated.
NFL celebrations.
Seriously,
how many times do we have to see these unoriginal athletes do the jump and the
chest bump after a touchdown?
It's been,
it's been done so much.
It's become lackluster and automatic.
Remember the throat slash they would all do before the NFL bandit for being too
violent.
A gesture.
I remember even Brett Farve doing that one and still managing to come off too
white when he did it.
Or what about the fact that the celebrations aren't even regulated to touchdowns
anymore?
Every sack tackle first down and catch warrants,
a dance and a,
hey look at me moment for the player.
This is the NFL.
I expect defenses to wrap a guy up and make a tackle.
Uh,
may expect to receive as the catch the ball.
They need to show some class and act like they've done it before.
Not to mention,
yeah,
I'm totally with you on that.
That whole,
every time you catch a pass and then you get up and you got it.
You know the Jerome Bettis was,
was the guy always stands out in my head where he would,
he would fucking,
you know,
his first 10 carries,
he get like 12 yards and then he ripped one off for like 11 and then he'd get up
and start stopping around,
taken off his fucking Chin strap.
I can't stand that shit.
Braylin Edwards does that Shit,
you know,
drops like nine passes and then catches one for a first down.
Gets up fucking,
ah,
it's the worst thing ever.
The Keyshawn Keyshawn Johnson.
Well you stomp around,
you take off you fucking Chin strap.
It's like,
well,
I,
I hate that shit.
I hate it.
I can't say.
I don't mind.
Actually we,
if you catch a touchdown,
you do a little fucking dance.
I actually,
I've always liked that shit.
But like the,
uh,
the first,
you know what's even worse is when your team is kicking the shit out of another
team and then the other team makes a good defensive play and then that guy gets
up Blah at screaming at the people in the end zone.
It's like,
dude,
you're,
you're down 28 to six.
All right,
why don't you go back to the defense of Huddle and figure out why the fuck you
weren't doing that for the first three and a half quarters,
you know,
so I go with you.
I'm a,
yeah,
I'm over all of that shit.
And uh,
I think the worst thing I saw this year was the t o show show.
Well,
you had a team that was absolutely shitting the bed,
yet their two best players had the time to do a reality show,
uh,
during the fucking,
during the season.
Do you think bill Bellacheck would put up with that?
Do you think that those guys would not be shipped out for third round draft
picks?
It's unfucking believable,
the level of disrespect that that is to do that fucking show
during the goddamn season as you proceed to lien ludes fucking eight games in a
row.
Uh Oh.
And then you go on the show and you throw your coaches under the bus,
they go,
um,
and for those of you who wonder why Randy Moss was traded for a third round
draft pick,
that's why,
because of that type of shit,
because it's really,
it's just not worth it.
Like you haven't see a beautiful girl in a bar.
Okay.
Or whatever.
You start dating a beautiful girl and no matter how hot she is,
she's just such a cunt.
It's not fucking worth it.
She's just so fucking high maintenance.
That's what all those players are like in all the,
all the,
all those types of sports.
It's at the end of the day,
no matter how fucking good they are,
they do.
They just not worth it.
It just not worth it.
Kind of like listening to the rest of this podcast.
It's really not worth it.
I feel like I haven't had anything to say for the last fucking 12 minutes.
Alright.
Underrated,
uh,
bat baseball's code,
although it's definitely borderline juvenile.
Sometimes.
I do like that in baseball.
If you show up a pitcher by celebrating your home,
run a little bit too much,
you can guarantee he's throwing at you the next time you're up.
I liked that players get to police themselves a little bit.
Well,
sir,
why don't you come over to the NHL?
You'd love Nhl Hockey.
You just basically described why there's fighting and hockey and why.
That's why hockey's awesome and uh,
you know,
cause they let the players police each other and I know people who don't like
the NHL,
they're going to be like by fighting.
Yes.
By fighting.
It has to be done.
Okay.
You got a guy skating around the ice if fucking 20 miles an hour with the
goddamn club in his hand.
Okay.
If you don't slap the shit out of him,
every couple of games,
he's going to hurt somebody severely.
You know?
So that's,
that's what needs to be done.
You know,
think of all the pieces of shit players that are cheap fucks in the NBA.
All right?
And in the NFL and all that,
just imagine if they actually had a club in their head and they could walk up to
your best player and just fucking slam 'em over the head,
right in the fucking grill or in the side of his fucking leg.
You know,
you'd have to beat the shit out.
You though,
are you have to be allowed to beat the shit out of that guy.
So it wouldn't happen.
And I know what you guys would thinking,
well if anybody does that just banned him for life out of the league.
Well then you would end up with nobody playing hockey because I don't know what
it is.
If you've ever played hockey,
there's something about it.
It's just a very physical game and at some point you're going to think about it,
that mother fucker gets you for like the fifth God damn time.
You just,
you got this club in your hand and you just use the,
I'm going to fucking come over there.
I'm just going to fucking take two hander right to his fucking neck.
But you doubt because their biggest player will come over there and beat the
living shit out of you in front of your fucking girlfriend or wife was in the
stance.
See to that makes sense.
Speaking of which,
I'm actually playing hockey tonight and yes,
I do suck.
I am upon hockey player.
I can only go frontwards and crossover on one side.
Okay.
I got the helmet with the full cage.
You know,
that's,
that's usually a sign that someone's going to be a cheap piece of shit.
Anybody who has all the extra padding,
that's because they know somebody is going to come up and try to retaliate.
So they want to make sure that they're,
they're extra protective.
I actually wear it because,
uh,
I know that my,
if I was ever gonna make it to the NHL,
it would have happened by now.
I'm going to go out on a limb and say that as a 42 year old,
I don't think I'm going to make it.
So there's really no point in me getting the required 18 stitches that starts
above my upper lip,
goes through my lips and comes down.
I remember the Gary Galley one that was the most insane fucking scar I've ever
seen.
Gary Galley,
former Bruins.
He's playing for the Boston,
but then you went to the kinks,
right?
He's playing for the Bruins.
He's in front of the net.
Somebody gets crosschecked in their chest.
The guy like he gets hit so hard that both his legs fly up into the air.
He's like in the air,
in the seated position.
He basically kicks Gary Galley in the face with his skate,
just sorta like as his legs are going up,
the blade of the guys skate catches Gary galleys.
Fucking Chin goes right through both his lips and right up the side of his face
and he had stitches from,
I think the side of his nose right down and write through both lips
in.
That was one of the worst ones I ever saw.
And uh,
you know,
and I think that's good to conclude one of the worst podcasts I've ever fucking,
uh,
I felt like a Sanchez during this whole podcast.
At no point that I feel comfortable.
I don't feel like I settled down.
I feel like all my jokes went 10 feet over everybody's fucking head.
And if I could have handed this mic off to somebody for the second half of it,
you know,
and let somebody kick the last joke through the uprights,
I would have.
Yeah.
Fuck,
I got to redeem myself.
Did anything funny happened to me this week?
I went out,
I looked at some houses.
I think I'm getting ready to go right back on the wheel again.
You know,
you have to talking about having no god damn dead.
I'm thinking about just going out and buying a house,
maybe buying a fucking car.
I want to buy something.
You know,
I want to fill the void like only an American can.
Somebody sent me an email talking about how America is over,
you know,
talking about how China is now.
Now they're now,
they're going to be the shit.
And you know what I say?
Well,
it's about fucking time.
You know,
China,
how many Goddamn fucking people the have to make before he can take over some
shit.
China,
that's the most overrated Goddamn fucking country out there.
You know,
they got like a third of the world's population.
How the fuck are you?
Not the best.
You should have.
The best guitar players,
the best singers,
the best actors,
the best scientist.
Just on a sheer fucking numbers.
What are you guys doing over there?
I've been slacking off.
Slacking off with your fucking awful food.
Ah,
you're dirty.
Goddamn restaurants.
Do you know I won't eat Chinese food because of that?
I'm not saying Chinese people.
A bad food,
a bad people,
bad food,
bad people.
It was like a,
that was like a Jeffrey Dahmer comment.
I'm not saying Chinese people are bad food.
I'm not saying that they're,
that they're bad people.
I'm not saying they're not smart.
I'm just saying.
I lived in New York City and uh,
I used to be a fan of Chinese food.
I am not a fan anymore.
All right.
And until they start getting some clean damn restaurants out there,
I'm not,
I'm not fucking eating at him.
That's it.
I'm not saying you're bad people.
I'm just saying what the fuck.
Filthy.
I only,
I'll only eat Chinese food.
Who's getting hope?
I'm shit faced.
I'll eat anything.
I don't give a fuck.
But if I'm sober and the only way I'll eat Chinese food is if it's a cloth
Napkin,
sit down.
Nice fucking place.
All right.
And it'd be fair.
That's why I don't eat barbecue.
I'm not going into those God damn shacks with those fucking flies
the size of Goddamn bumblebees.
I'm not going in there and I get it.
That's the whole aids boy.
You poor people food.
Yeah.
It looks like it.
It looks like you've been dominated on some fucking level.
Oh,
with the dirty floors and the peanut shells.
Fuck Barbecue and fuck Chinese food.
All right.
I actually had some Lebanese food,
uh,
yesterday,
which is just sort of all like Middle Eastern food like that,
that a chicken kabobs and all that stuff was fucking insane to Bouley Salad.
All right.
I sign off on that.
I sign off on Indian food.
I sign off on a,
these are all the ones I'll give you a that I like.
I like a Japanese,
I'll go with Korean barbecue,
we'll go with that.
Thai food.
I liked that shit.
Chinese,
I think Chinese was the only one I won't fuck with.
You know,
and I'm Mexican food.
Mexican food has to be a certain cut or I'm not fucking with it.
You know when you go to the,
so some of those,
some of those little shits Jack's there and they got to have the refi re fried
beans and it just looks like,
you know,
it's like does the health department even know this place exists?
Okay.
This is like a restaurant slash
it's like you turn the garage,
he house into a fucking burrito factory.
I'm not eating here.
Macro.
Alexia gives me shit because I'll never get Chinese food.
You know?
And she thinks that that there's something like borderline racist that I won't
eat Chinese food.
It's like I have no problem with those people.
You know,
that's like over like overly think it's something.
What I'm saying is is I want a clean God damn restaurant.
Is that so wrong?
Um,
all right.
That's the podcast for this fucking week.
Um,
I dunno.
I am.
I am I wrong about that shit I just did when I think Chinese food,
I think dirty restaurant.
That's,
that's what the fuck I think because that has been my experience.
So go ahead.
We're going to take the next call after this break.
Uh,
Hey,
what would you guys do if I started doing commercials on my podcast as a way to
make money if right in the middle of calling somebody a cunt.
I just did something for like true value hardware.
Do they still exist or where they bought out?
Bought up by best buy.
Do they still exist?
All right.
Anyways.
Oh,
you know what?
I actually forgot tonight then.
I can't say this shit because I
now fuck it.
I'm going to say it.
I'm actually gonna go see one of my favorite drummers of all time tonight.
And,
uh,
Joe Joe Mayor is doing a drum clinic and I'm going to go check that shit out.
And uh,
if you want to see this guy drummers out there,
you got to fucking check this guy out.
This is going to,
I'm going to have this up on the MM podcast.com.
Uh,
it's Joe Joe mayor performing.
I plays like that drum in a drum and bass music and it's him performing at the,
I believe 2005 modern drummer festival.
And it's just a three minute clip.
He could do like a role with one hand.
He's got that push pull molar thing.
I don't know what the fuck he's doing,
but uh,
this guy is the shit and I'm actually starting to like,
I can't get into drum and bass,
but I'm downloading some of his shit just because it's played by human beings
and I'm actually fascinated with drum and bass because it,
it melds both the capabilities of technology and then the abilities of human
beings to adapt to the technology and raise their level of performance.
You know,
remember that time when I told you guys about that,
that whole,
uh,
drum and bass music,
that whole video,
I basically explained it.
It was like a fucking drum brake from a B side of a 45.
And then Djs took that drum loop,
isolated every sound,
and then switched it all up and created a whole bunch of different beats and
then sped it up to the point that no human being could play it until a guy like
Joe Joe mayor sat down and figured out how to fucking do it.
It's,
it's incredible.
It's absolutely incredible.
I'm going to watch that guy tonight.
I'm going to get my ass kicked out on the ice tonight playing hockey and that's
it.
I'm going to be in New York and uh,
we doing spots,
uh,
around the city before I go down to Atlantic city.
So I make sure that I am in shape for my,
uh,
my big gig down there with Jim Norton,
Jim Breuer and David Tell,
uh,
I will probably be popping in at Gotham comedy club.
I will be popping in at the comedy cellar
and a stand up New York and Co the comic strip and danger fields on,
they'd be doing the whole fucking loop.
Like I used to back in the old days,
back in the old days,
which I guess they don't do that anymore now.
They booked the club's a month out and they just want you to work at the,
at the same club the whole week.
But back in the day,
he used to,
used to work like three,
four clubs.
If you could on a weekend and you'd,
you'd,
you'd have a nine o'clock here at nine 45 and another club at 10 20 here and
1130 here all the way to like two o'clock in the morning and you get $50 a spot
and you'd blow like a third of it on cabs just driving all around the city and
you'd have a new idea for a bit.
And uh,
in one night you could hash it out just doing like,
you know,
sometimes up.
I think the most I ever did,
I do like eight sets in a night.
It was fucking unbelievable and it just caused you to write because you didn't
want to say the same thing eight times in one night and uh,
you could,
you could flesh out a bit.
I mean that was basically like doing,
you know,
almost headline weekends you only do six shows so you would get eight shows on
average six.
So it was like doing an entire weekend worth of shows in one night as far as
running that same new bit and it's incredible.
And I wish the New York clubs would go back to doing that because I really think
that that was the system that created all the great comics that I watched when I
came to New York.
That's just my,
that's my 2 cents and I'll fucking sticker with that.
That's it.
You guys watch 60 minutes by the way,
that just reminded me of fucking Andy Rooney guys been watching.
I watch that every week.
Me in the eye and we just laugh our asses off at their curmudgeonly old bastard
and what the fuck is going on with his upper lip?
It's receded on both sides yet the middle part still is fleshy.
So now it looks like he has a pimple.
It's upper lip.
All right,
I got nothing people.
I'm talking about fucking Andy Rooney's upper lip.
Okay.
The podcast is overbuilt.
Tap Out.
It's over.
Oh,
congratulations to Pete Carroll.
I was wrong about that.
Docker wearing white shoes.
Jerry Seinfeld,
sneaker son of a bitch.
They came out to fucking play.
Worse defensive performance I've ever seen with the saints.
And uh,
I don't know.
I don't even know who the fuck they're playing next week.
I'm just hoping that my patriots and praying that we're going to beat the jets
cause I have no fucking idea which defense is going to show up.
But I'll phone the patriots are got to be thinking.
All right,
that's the podcast for this week.
Everybody have a great week.
Uh,
don't give out your information to these fucking corporation for the love of
God.
And if you want to go ahead and do it stupid.
All right,
go ahead and do it.
But then don't be surprised when a,
you know,
some psycho you dated from high school is standing on your front porch and has
your fucking now all your information.
All right.
I couldn't even finish that sentence to gives us,
fuck.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I'll talk to you next week.
[inaudible]
okay.